Brian Ennis is one of the lead police
officers he's there he's been on the
scene with these people now they've been
peaceful tonight and they're getting on
their knees cooperating and getting
arrested as this curfew now has been in
effect for some time tonight but Brian
Ennis is on the scene there and talking
I believe with one of the lead police
officers Brian Shawn yeah this is the
chief of Department Terry Monahan she
talked to me about what just happened
here how many people were arrested and
why were they arrested this is the
bullet we've been walking around for a
long time for hours on cops with all
who's been giving them the streets
giving them room to protest eight
o'clock is up curfew this is the area
that we've had our issues in over the
last few nights everyone knows what's
happened here we gave a warning for a
while
curfew is in effect curfews in effect no
one wanted to leave so we bought out
teams in we made 60 arrests and we were
able to disperse the rest of the crowds
you talk about what is it that you guys
have been facing from day one Thursday
night we've been facing rocks bottles
brick you can shot at we've been run
over by cars but they're still out there
as you can see in force keeping the city
safe being extremely effective out there
doing the job making sure that the city
is how City we are one with the
protesters were out there for justified
cause but now with the people who are
the cause mayhem to love city you gotten
a lot of criticism or some criticism for
me governor say the NYPD hasn't done its
job haven't didn't do enough just tell
me what's your response to that listen I
don't want to go back and forth with the
governor the governor's the governor all
I know is what my men and women through
every day as you saw here we move in
tactically we take people out we will
let people leave we allow people to
protest if they protest but they start
violating the law we're gonna take
action and we are going to make sure
that we have the city under control
all right Brian please tell the officers
thank you and to please keep him in has
men safe and it's not an easy job